there are a few types of people in this
world those who love Twitter those who
love Kanye West on Twitter those who
could care less about Twitter and those
who have fled Twitter because well
because of a lot of things
Twitter's in trouble not only because it
isn't attracting new users but current
users of the service are becoming less
active twitter is aggressively releasing
new features and fixes but is it really
addressing the biggest frustrations now
I'm one of those Twitter lovers so I
tracked down dozens of my followers who
have left the service to find out why
and no it wasn't because of my bad
tweets my biggest problem with Twitter
is the newsfeed if I'm away from it for
any amount of time at all it's very
confusing to me when I come back and
that's the complaint I've heard the most
and the one Twitter's actively improving
the timeline consists of a long reverse
chronological list of the tweets from
people you follow but a new setting puts
tweets that Twitter thinks you'll care
most about at the top of your feed it's
similar to Facebook and I found it very
useful too bad Twitter's buried the
switch to turn it on in its iOS Android
and web apps I didn't really know who I
was treating to no one responded so stop
tweeting there are some solutions to
this but the best one may be accepting
that Facebook is for conversation and
Twitter is mainly a spectator sport you
can try to get more followers by
improving your tweets with short videos
and photos the new jiff button is an
attempt to help with that you could also
use and add hashtags to join
conversations and you know who will
likely listen when you need them too
many customers service accounts for
brands but it's okay to use Twitter only
as a newswire for the latest on politics
sports celebrities etc the new moments
tab makes it easy to get news but you
can also try a service like nuzzle which
makes it easy to see the top stories
being circulated by your followers I'm
really tech savvy but I just find it
complicated and hard to understand
sometimes I just think I'm not using it
right
chances are you weren't using it right
and you're not entirely to blame
learning Twitter's like learning a
secret language of pound signs at
symbols retweets DMS you name it
sure Twitter has released some
instructional videos but some of these
features need some more basic
explanation so retweets are quotes but
quote tweets are new tweets there are
more features on the way though that
will keep making the service easier to
use including a way to respond to a
friend so everyone can see your response
no awkward period needed a way to find
new people to follow and an option to
write longer than 140 character tweets
those features aren't arriving fast
enough though people are sticking with
Facebook which has taken some of the
best attributes from Twitter still if
your Twitter quitter or you've never
used the service the new timeline and
other tweaks make it worth a shot I mean
where else you going to get this kind of
pressing news